الآن تقول أنه ستكون هناك تداعيات
على زيارة بيلوسي ، نحن نشهد
بالفعل حصارًا من نوع ما حول تايوان ،
ما رأيك سنراه
جيدًا ، لا أعتقد أن الرئيس الحادي عشر
في نهاية اليوم يريد حقًا
إثارة الصراع هنا
يبدو أن أه كلماته تشير إلى
أنه لم يخرج
لخوض معركة ردًا على هذا
الإجراء الذي حدث والذي
كان أمرًا محرجًا على أقل تقدير ،
خاصة في واشنطن حيث
يقال أن رئيس جيش الأمن القومي
يثني عن
هذا المتحدث.  المضي قدمًا في قول الآخرين
إن المتحدث على حق ،
ولكن مرة أخرى ، فإن توقيت هذا صعب للغاية على
وجه الخصوص لأن
الرئيس الحادي عشر دعونا نتذكر أنه في
موسم الانتخابات ، كما أنه على بعد ثلاثة
أشهر من تجمع
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
الذي يفترض  إعادة انتخابه
لولاية ثالثة غير مسبوقة كزعيم للحزب
يتبعها إعادة انتخابه
كرئيس وقائد
للمفوضية العسكرية  لقد أراد
طريقًا سلسًا لهذه الرحلة تحديدًا في
هذا
الوقت وبهذه الطريقة
تجبره حقًا على أن يكون قوميًا متطرفًا
عليه أن يُظهر أنه أقوى من
كل البقية لذلك سترى هذه التدريبات بالذخيرة الحية في
جميع أنحاء الجزيرة  من
تايوان ، سترى الطائرات
تعود إلى المجال الجوي وما إلى ذلك ،
أعتقد أننا سنرى كل هذا وأعتقد أن
هذا قد يحدث مع مرور الوقت
أيضًا ، ولن يكون هذا فقط
لأنك تعرف موجة من النشاط
الآن هناك  يمكن أن تكون هناك
تداعيات أخرى على الخط ، هناك
أيضًا بعض العقوبات الاقتصادية
التي تم فرضها على تايوان نتيجة لذلك
أيضًا ، لذا سيستغرق هذا بعض الوقت
لتلعب ، لا أرى أي
تعارض الآن ، لا أعتقد أن هذا
لمصلحته أو مصلحة الصين ولكن من
الواضح أننا وضعنا
قواتنا وقدراتنا حتى نتمكن من فعل ما
هو ضروري أه إذا تعلق الأمر بذلك